hello and welcome to med simplified
in this video we will discuss about diet
and foods that are very good for people
suffering from depression
depression is a common illness worldwide
and it is estimated that more than 264
million people
across the globe suffer from depression
and it is the second leading cause of
death in the 15 to 29 year age group
depression affects many people and it
can be life-changing
medical treatment and counselling can
often help relieve symptoms
but lifestyle remedies such as a
healthful diet can also boost a person's
well-being
diet is such an important component of
mental health that it has inspired an
entire field of medicine
called nutritional psychiatry this field
of medicine has studied that what we eat
matters for every aspect of our health
but especially our mental health
and it also explores the effect of
nutritional changes on mental health
inflammation in the brain is thought to
be a major cause of mental health
illnesses
and this inflammation can also come from
a long period of poor eating
healthy eating can protect against this
inflammation
and can even improve our cognitive
function which is a fancy word that
describes our ability
to attain new information reason with
people
remember things and pay attention one
analysis concluded that a dietary
pattern characterized by a high intake
of fruits
vegetables whole grains fish olive oil
low-fat dairy antioxidants and low
intake of animal foods
was apparently associated with a
decreased risk of depression
and a dietary pattern characterized by
high consumption of red processed meat
refined grains sweets high fat products
butter and low intake of fruits and
vegetables was associated with an
increased risk of depression
well in this video we will discuss seven
such types of foods that are very good
for people
with depression and other mood related
disorders
our bodies normally make molecules
called free radicals during the
inflammation
and these can lead to cell damage aging
and other problems
studies show that your brain is
particularly at risk
although there's no way to stop free
radicals completely
but you can lessen their destructive
effect by eating foods
rich in antioxidants here are some
important antioxidants and the foods
that contain them
beta carotene which is found in apricots
broccoli
carrots collards peaches pumpkins
spinach and sweet potatoes is a very
important antioxidant for mental health
vitamin c is also a very good
antioxidant
and is found in lemons limes blueberries
broccoli
grapefruit kiwis oranges peppers
strawberries tomatoes etc vitamin e is
also good and is present in
nuts and seeds vegetable oils vegemite
oil
kiwis and avocados
carbohydrates are linked to the mood
elevating brain chemical
serotonin experts aren't sure but
carbohydrate
cravings may be related to low serotonin
activity
also according to a study by columbia
medical center in 2015
a diet high in refined carbohydrates may
lead to an increased risk for new onset
depression
in post-menopausal women so choose your
carbs wisely
limit sugary foods and opt for smart or
complex carbohydrates
such as whole grains and legumes rather
than simple carbs such as white bread
rice cakes and cookies fruits and
vegetables like bananas sweet potatoes
peas
broccoli and oats also have healthy
carbohydrates and fiber
amino acids which are the building
blocks of protein play an
important role in the production of
neurotransmitters
neurotransmitters are the chemicals
which allow brain cells to communicate
with each other and the rest of the body
the two neurotransmitters that are
affected by your protein intake are
dopamine and serotonin
which are the most important
neurotransmitters that regulate our mood
and behavior
for example when you eat a piece of
chicken your body breaks down the
protein
and synthesizes the amino acid
l-tyrosine
to produce dopamine the amino acid
tryptophan which is also produced and
proteins are digested
can help your brain to produce serotonin
elevated levels of serotonin are
associated with
improved mood and brain cognition while
lower levels are associated with
depression
try to eat something protein rich
several times a day
especially when you need to clear your
mind and boost your energy
good sources of healthy proteins include
beans peas
lean beef low fat cheese fish milk
poultry soy products and yogurt
[Music]
vitamin b12 and other b vitamins play an
important role in producing brain
chemicals
that affect mood and other brain
functions
low levels of vitamin b12 and other b
vitamins such as vitamin b6
and folate can link to depression
a spanish study found that rates of
depression are higher in males
especially smokers as they got less
folate
the same thing happened for women
especially those who smoked or didn't
exercise
low levels of vitamin b can result from
eating a poor diet or not being able to
absorb the vitamins you consume
older adults vegetarians and people with
digestive disorders such as celiac
disease or crohn's disease
may have trouble getting enough vitamin
b12 sometimes a vitamin b12 deficiency
can also occur for unknown reasons also
vitamin b containing foods include
legumes
nuts many fruits and dark green
vegetables
vitamin b12 can be found in all lean and
low fat animal products such as fish
low fat dairy and many other animal
products
vitamin d receptors are located
throughout the body including your brain
a recent national study found that the
likelihood of having depression
is higher in people with low levels of
vitamin d
research has also shown that vitamin d
might play an important role in
regulating mood
and preventing depression in one study
scientists found that people with
depression who received vitamin d
supplements noticed
an improvement in their symptoms vitamin
d is known as the
sunshine vitamin because our bodies
produce it when exposed to sunlight
vitamin d is also present in milk and
other foods
and is available in small amounts in
fatty fish like tuna
salmon and mackerel beef liver cheese
and egg yolks
also have vitamin d it can be hard to
get the required amount from our diets
which is why
supplements are often prescribed by
physicians
studies have reported a link between low
selenium and poor moods
the recommended amount of selenium is 55
micrograms a day for adults
evidence isn't clear that taking
selenium supplements can help
and it is possible to get too much
selenium so it is probably best to focus
on foods and avoid supplements
foods that contain serenium include
beans and legumes
lean meat lean pork and beef chicken
and turkey low-fat dairy products
nuts and seeds especially brazil nuts
but no more than
one or two a day because of their high
selenium content
seafood like oysters clams sardines
crabs salt water fish are also good
sources of selenium
whole grains such as whole grain pasta
brown rice
oatmeal also contain this trace element
[Music]
recently scientists have found that
people that don't eat enough omega-3s
may have higher rates of major
depressive disorders
because depression appears less common
in nations where people ate large
amounts of fish
scientists have investigated whether
fish oils
may prevent or even treat depression and
other mood-related disorders
good sources of omega-3s including alpha
linoleic
acid are fatty fish like mackerel salmon
sardines shad and tuna flax seed
canola and soybean oils nuts especially
walnuts
dark green leafy vegetables mental
health is a very important issue
especially for our generation our mental
health affects how we think
feel and act as we cope with life
it also helps to determine how we handle
stress relate to others
and make choices i am going to make many
such videos on mental health in the
future
so if you are interested in this topic
make sure to subscribe to our channel
if you found our videos helpful you can
support med simplified by making a small
donation on patreon.com
med simplified or you can also join our
channel here on youtube and get members
only exclusive content
like exclusive posts behind the scenes
of our videos
and much more well thank you so much for
watching this video
see you in the next one